segue in that so you've made some
comments that some people deem
controversial right you've talked about
gender you've talked about women you've
talked about uh uh fat shaming
necessarily Society religion there's
some things that you've said that people
have vly disagreed with and then some
people that're like hell yeah Pearl
nailed it someone needed to say it
that's kind of how the way it works is
when you take a stance on something
you're going to have allies and then
you're going to have people basically uh
forming sort of enemy camp so but we
also know
especially um with social media and
YouTube and long form content that short
clips and little reels and clips can be
taken out of context right so you've
said a lot of things out of everything
you've said uh is what do you think has
been the most misconstrued about you uh
and if there's anything you would walk
back what would it be there's anything
I'd walk I don't I can't really think of
much you stand by all your your
statements um I don't know it's it's
tough cuz I've said so many things but
there's nothing that really comes to the
top of my head you know
[Music]
um H I would say one of the most
misconstrued things is people think I
hate women that's like something I get
247 but I I think you know we can't
really have progress if we're not honest
so I I just I'm all about honesty got it
so why do you think people think you
hate ha women oh cuz I say things like
women are dumber than
men yeah and you stand by that oh yeah
so okay so women I just look at I just
look at the top women and the top men
it's like Kim Kardashian or Elon Musk
right like what conclusion am I supposed
to come to when literally all the female
billionaires um like tend to be
billionaires through sex work or through
divorce exactly yeah
Bezos um Steve Jobs wife the list goes
on and on and on yeah so you know some
people take that offensively um and I
mean it so yeah you can be mad so
nothing you're not walking anything back
Stand by Your statements that's how you
know you're a True Believer you're like
I wish I could have a mulligan and take
that thing back but the Miss I'm sure
there is something I talk so much I just
can't think of it now I mean but the
biggest misconception is that you hate
women but you're saying that you don't
but how do you feel about
women I just think the last 100 years
you know we've been given more freedom
than ever and we've made terrible
choices as a group you know I just think
when you look at the numbers you can't
really dispute that right so 100 years
ago 85% of women are virgins now we have
more only fans models than teachers MH
like you know what I mean like what what
conclusion am I supposed to come to when
I look at these numbers got it what else
do you think are women getting terribly
wrong in modern
society um I would just say women
typically want a lot of freedom without
the responsibility that comes with it I
don't have any problem with you know
women having freedom but you should also
have the responsibility that comes with
it that's why women shouldn't vote
because they don't want to do the
infrastructure jobs they don't want to
be net taxpayers and they want to take
money for men through divorce and
alimony and I think if you're going to
do that most women do I think you should
not be able to vote Yes got it which is
also something we're going to discuss
today so Nat yes uh news flash you're a
woman yes I am okay so um we're going to
get into a lot of stuff today when Pearl
says things like look you're just you're
dumber than me Nat I mean that's not a
crazy controversial topic to be honest
with you she also says someone like you
shouldn't vote how do you process smar I
think she's smarter than some guys
though yeah okay here's my thing is that
I'm not going to compare a man to a
woman you know they're meant to be doing
different things so for you to say oh a
man is stronger than a woman woman or a
man is smarter than a woman and you know
as essentially a man's resources and the
things they have to do it does give them
the skills to be smarter they're
supposed to be smarter they're they're
leading they're guiding so like things
like that I'm also considering like
things certain things don't trigger me
because I may not feel like I'm in that
boat of like I'm arguing with a man like
if they're smarter with me now men are
more resourceful for sure there's
there's there's a there's a point of
Truth which is which is supposed to be
like biologic
but at the end of day a woman's role is
completely different than a man so for
me it's like you know that's kind of
just you ever seen that have you ever
seen that um episode of Survivor where
they put like a bunch of women on an
island a bunch of men on an island How
does it go and the men are like they
have like a whole system running they're
like yeah there's like a fire going like
they're resourceful and the women
basically to be rescued yeah but here's
the thing though I mean as it should
like I wouldn't I mean what is a woman
supposed to do like go and and be good
at those things and not not have that
nurture side as well so there's
strengths and there's weakness women
aren't even more nurturing yeah I
disagree with that well I disagree
completely I think if you want to look
at nurturing who's the most likely one
to kill infants and the elderly women so
I actually think we have all this
propaganda saying like women are so
nurturing and all this stuff when you
say let me say that for a second when
you say the infants and the elderly
you're saying abortion no both so even
they kill the they're more likely to
kill the elderly in what regard like are
more likely to kill an elderly person
like Asia no like like violent like in
nursing homes that sort of thing like
you'll see the you'll see the cases pop
up in the news where these these female
nurses that's even more mental health
that's where a woman's mentality maybe
is not as strong enough as a man so
again it kind of goes back to what
you're comparing comparing apples
actually I think no I think women are
more violent than men um and if you look
at one-sided abuse 70% of the time it's
um women hitting the men and not men
hitting the women so I actually would
argue that women are more violent than
men they just can't be and I also think
that and so infant side so a woman
killing or someone killing a baby within
the first 24 hours of life is very rare
for a male to do that like it's like
almost unheard of so then but how many
males are in that division to be
comparing how many women what do you
mean how are they measuring that like
the amount of women in that field right
there's a lot more women in that field
than men are you talking about nursing
well I I mean parenting there's usually
a dad and a mom and I'm talking about
like nursing for example right you see
more women nurses there so those numbers
make sense but it's not new so and this
is this is the thing like a lot of times
the stuff you see today you think is new
it's not new in the 1800s women were
also more likely to kill infants even
before abortion before nursing before
all this stuff interesting Malik run a
poll who's more nurturing men or women
listen we're going to have a wild array
of conversations we're going to talk
about hold on that we're going to talk
about an array of topics I've never
heard in my life that that men are more
nurturing than women so what made you
come to that well I just the conclusion
I came to was you know when I think of
nurturing I think of how do you interact
with the innocent and I I guess more of
my point is that women are more violent
than men I would argue because I think
women are more likely to kill the
innocent where men are not I think men
just tend to be better people in general
yes
so men are better people yeah and I'll
tell you why I think there's reasons for
that because typically if one guy is
being too bad of a person another guy
will come and check him where women
don't necessarily have that even if you
look at prison sentences you see these
women that constantly get bailed out of
bad decisions so like Casey Anthony got
let out of jail right she's she's
remarried now and you'll see cases like
that all the time women don't get the
same sentences that men get when it
comes to prison sentences as well I just
I I don't see women having the same
consequences in society and I just I
think women have a harder time
regulating emotion so I that's why I
think they're more violent personally
well it also comes down to the amount of
Freedom that has been given too because
women have gone numbers have gotten to
this point as well based on the
eligibility that women can do certain
things now so now that they have more
freedom to do things maybe they don't
know how to handle certain emotions
behaviors maybe they should again I said
this isn't this isn't new that's that
was what I said before so even before
they had the freedom of the right to
vote women were still more likely to
kill infants in the 1800s 1700s 1600s
this is not new so can it be attributed
to the fact that um know men are more
hierarchal women are more egalitarian so
if you look at a spectrum of things men
by a wide margin are going to be smarter
stronger wealthier more uh in in your
regard more uh nurturing more protective
where women sort of associate in the
middle of the Spectrum more egalitarian
and then all the way to the left more
men are psychopaths murderers absolute
idiots more men are homeless uh and just
don't win in life so it's more like men
are on the opposite sides of the
spectrum whereas women sort of so we
would have to go we would have to go
through each and every one of those so
if you wanted to go through homeless I
would argue that more women would be
homeless if they actually face
consequences for their decisions um if
you want to go based what was the other
things you said Homeless um aric
murderers vicious so even Mur hom that's
like like women cannot murder in the
same way men can murder I I would argue
one I don't think they're smart enough
to pull it off I don't think you're
going to get a wom and Ted Bundy the
same way you're not going to get a woman
there's some out there but not as many
as men not as many that's that's my
point I think I think men are more
likely to get away with it for longer um
but the second thing I would say is
that um I I would argue that wait sorry
what was what was the second one all the
vicious crimes oh the vicious crimes
again you have to look at abuse and who
murders the innocent women cannot be
violent in the same way men can be
violent they can't but when they can be
violent they are more likely to kill the
innocent so when women have the
opportunity to be violent towards the
infants and the elderly they are more
likely to kill got it and is that kind
of an ask question is that just sort of
a circumstantial meaning they're around
more infants they're the ones dealing
with actual babies cares nurseries or
even women are way more inclined to go
into nursing and health care so they're
just kind of in that situation so by the
law of large numbers they're going to be
more likely so you that's like saying
men are more likely to kill other people
at War yeah because 95% of the military
is men so interesting it's like whenever
there's a bad stat about women we always
have this like gut reaction to like give
a reason or an excuse but no this in
this is even 187 these are completely
different time periods women were always
more likely to kill the infants and the
elderly so look I'm I'm here to have a
actual convers I've never you know you
said that you think that men are more
nurturing than women I that's the first
time I've ever heard that right I think
that men U will do more right out of
unconditional love for a woman whereas a
lot of women will have conditions in
order to give love right like a man must
be this this this this this and this
whereas a guy just like yeah she's hot
she's cool and she's a uh loyal girl I
I'll give her the world whereas a woman
wants six foot six packs six figures
this that funny crazy this all that
stuff so there there's a longer
checklist of what a man uh that a woman
is looking for versus what a man is
looking
for yeah but that that we were talking
about like nurturing kids I thought no
but also but no you just said nurturing
you said nurturing kids I'm saying in
general women would be considered more
nurturing but also have I just I just
think like we have to like whenever
women have like something that describes
women that makes them so special and
awesome it's always something that can't
be measured and whenever you measure it
the stats never line up and so that's
that's an example I'm giving where it's
like if we were more nurturing wouldn't
we be less likely to kill our children
so to just to kind of put a ribbon on
this um you know I I said what's the
biggest misconception about you you said
well people think I hate women yeah but
it doesn't seem like you speak fondly of
women so what would you describe your
relationship with women if you can sum
it
up what's my relationship like with
women no just like the the concept of
women I I like women I like guys you
know okay I mean it's not no there's no
doubt that you I just don't I just don't
think like I think there's a lot of
propaganda that says women are these
special amazing purpose do you find
purpose let answer the question I just
think that there's all of this
propaganda that always says women are so
special and amazing and awesome and I
just think women are people the same way
men are people they're special women
they're special men you know but I I
just think as a group you know they're
just normal people yeah okay but I do
think they're more violent than men I'll
die on that Hill actually every time
I've been attacked like physically like
threatened always a woman I hope so if
it's not a man I hope not okay so um you
don't hate women you just think they're
not special is that fair to say yeah I
know I think most people aren't special
but the difference is men know that
women not as much yeah I don't see men
running around being like I'm a king I'm
the man no matter what you say it's like
buddy you're broke you're homeless you
live with your mom you have three socks
to your name whereas women they're all
queens no matter what their situation
well I came to this Con I came to this
conclusion was I I literally couldn't
think of one thing that women are better
at I couldn't because every time I had
to measure it and put a number to it I
have one thing okay please it's going to
be super controversial okay uh giving
birth I hope so that's kind of the one
thing women do create life I do love my
mom and my grandma out if men could
figure out a way to do it I would argue
they'd figure out a way to do it well
let's hope they don't because they're
trying to have that happen for uh Malik
what do you do by the way never never
okay got it me me too okay I hope not um
so moving on uh good to set the tone I
like it I understand it um